so I'm here with Stu shmall Dean of
Admissions at MIT thanks for joining me
sure happy to Sal so so what I wanted to
ask you about is it's just a general
notion of well of course college
admissions but in particular you know
there tends to be some stereotypes in
terms of what makes a competitive
applicant and I'll just throw out at
least my stereotype of you take I don't
know five six AP courses and you do
really well on them you have a very high
SAT score your GPA is near-perfect
you're close to the top of your class
you had your you know your vice
president or president of three or four
clubs you you know your play first viola
and the symphony or whatever whatever it
might be all of those so so how much
truth is that is there to that and and
or not I think the things that you've
just described are components uh that a
certain student might have as part of
their application and it is not the
first way that we think about evaluating
students so we think about trying to
enroll students that are going to
succeed academically on our campuses who
are going to be a well matched to our
institution so that the kinds of things
that motivates those students they get
them excited are the things and the
culture on our campus and then we think
about what kind of contributions that
those students might be able to make to
our campuses which might mean any
particular kinds of talent that they
have but also how engage they're going
to be can the life of the universe so
that's really the lens that we're
looking through and students can
manifest those things and demonstrate
those things in different ways so you
talked about the number of KP classes
and things like that that students might
have and you know for us we're looking
at
choices that students have made around
their academics but also their
non-academic so academically we want to
see that students are challenging
themselves in the things that really
interest them and students can do that
in any number of different weddings AP
classes may be one but there are other
ways of doing that as well and not all
students that have even access to AP
classes and it's not as though there's a
particular tally or score sheet that we
have where we're looking at a student's
record and saying they have to have
certain markers because really there are
all different kinds of markers all
different ways that students can
demonstrate these different talents
so certainly academically as I said
earlier not all students have access to
taking AP classes so there may be other
ways that students can demonstrate to us
that academically they're going to be
ready to succeed on our campus so there
are these two realities on one extreme
you have and this is maybe the more
traditional reality the students taking
a lot of very rigorous courses doing a
lot of homework staying until 2:00 in
the morning
they're very stressed out they frankly
don't have time to pursue their passions
on the other side you could have
students who aren't in a traditional
system maybe and maybe I don't even have
traditional grades but they're able to
show evidence of their academic
knowledge through standardized tests
through maybe they take things like the
AP tests themselves maybe the
independent study for it maybe they take
some college courses but they have more
time to pursue their passions and build
portfolios I mean on some levels based
on what I'm hearing it sounds like that
second student might even be at an
advantage I think students that are
overloading themselves their coursework
where they don't leave any time for
anything else are definitely doing
themselves a disservice I think students
against challenge themselves in areas
that interest them but I think students
also really need to leave themselves
time and capacity to pursue more
independent
projects independent I don't mean by
themselves independent projects could
mean with other people certainly but
these other projects that allow students
to use some creativity and independent
thought and coming up with some new and
interesting things and whatever topics
interest them oh those are the kinds of
things that we also really like to see
students submit as part of their
application we really like to see it and
those kinds of projects can really help
students because it can show that it can
show us kinds of things that students
might want to pursue once they come to
campus and so on the academic side
really we're just looking for evidence
that students are talented and capable
and that they're going to do well and
beyond that we're looking at the rest of
it and those into the portfolio's of
students can submit showing the
independent work that they've done can
really enhance their applications so the
student you know just to make it
concrete a student with strong SAT
scores ones that would show are a CT
scores that show evidence that they
would do well at a place like MIT strong
maybe ap scores and the rigorous ones
that they they have an interest in plus
a portfolio of things that they've you
know substantive things that they've
done not just kind of cookbook projects
but things that were really show their
passions they would have a strong
application
those students would have a very strong
application so I mean that brings up
another interesting dimension I mean at
the other extreme end of this you do
have some homeschool students you have
this unschooling movement but how do you
evaluate those students and I actually
even compared them relative to the
students who are taking the 5 AP classes
at a traditional college prep school
right so I think thinking about
homeschool students is a great a great
way to demonstrate the fact that it's
not just about the AP classes because we
have a home school students we're very
successful and do successful in our
process certainly but also become very
successful once at MIT we do need
evidence though that they're going to do
well
and there are a number of ways that
students can demonstrate that to us it
is one of the reasons why we require
standardized tests I mean that's one
piece of information it's not all of it
but it's one some students right who are
not in traditional schooling pathways
will still take classes in less
traditional ways so some will take
classes at local colleges for example
and be able to demonstrate their ability
that way and you know then there are
other various kinds of ways students can
do it
for example the American math
competition offers these competitions
where students who have a high ability
in math can can do well on these exams
and progress towards and through the
Olympiad program and it's a way for
students to demonstrate again their
talents at least in math so that's one
example in there are other ways like
that so we were open to evaluating all
kinds of evidence that students can
present to us to demonstrate their
ability to succeed once they come here
yeah well thank you I think that this is
a really exciting I think I have some
young people I need to call and tell
them tell me well that's great send them
our way